Wir wissen, dass potenzielle
«Amoktäter»
sich sehr für andere Amoktaten interessieren.
Solche dann oft als Anlass nehmen,
umzusetzen, was sie
schon längere Zeit geplant haben.
Frank Urbaniok ist der einflussreichste
und wohl auch bekannteste
Gerichtspsychiater der Schweiz.
Wenn die Medien Fragen haben, liefert er Antworten.
Wir sprechen mit ihm über die
eindrücklichsten Fälle mit denen er als
Gutachter zu tun hatte.
Am 27. September 2001 stürmt
ein schwer bewaffneter Mann
in das Kantonsparlament in Zug.
Er tötete dort 14 Anwesende
und verletzte zahlreiche zum Teil schwer.
Er selber tötete sich noch am Tatort.
Vorausgegangen war
eine Kneipen-Auseinandersetzung,
drei Jahre zuvor,
in deren Rahmen der Täter,
einen Busfahrer mit einer
Schusswaffe bedrohte.
Das gab eine Strafermittlung.
Der Täter selber startete eine
Kampagne gegen den Busfahrer,
er beschuldigte ihn als Alkoholiker
und diffamierte ihn.
Er versuchte das Strafverfahren
mit ganz vielen Eingaben zu sabotieren.
Das führte wiederum zu Anzeigen
seitens der
Zuger Verkehrsbetriebe,
auf die er dann wieder mit neuen
Kampagnen und Eingaben reagierte.
Drei Tage zuvor wurden alle
Beschwerden vom Obergericht abgewiesen.
Friedrich Leibacher gelangte
daraufhin mit mehreren Waffen
und einem Sprengsatz unbehelligt
ins Zuger Parlamentsgebäude,
gekleidet in einer selbst
gefertigten Polizeiuniform.
Es ist vollkommen absurd
zu sagen, dass es
sich hier um einen braven Bürger handelt,
der die Kontrolle verliert,
weil er durch die Behörden
schikaniert wurde.
Das ist eine Person, die
seit Jugendjahren auffällig ist,
mit Gewalttaten, mit Eigentumsdelikten.
Das zieht sich wie ein roter Faden
durch die ganze Geschichte.
Es zieht sich auch durch die Geschichte,
dass er ein grosses Geschick hatte,
den Spiess umzukehren.
Wurde er beschuldigt, reagierte er
mit Gegenbeschuldigungen,
mit Kampagnen und Eingaben.
Er hatte auch einige Semester Jura studiert
und hatte sich damit ein Wissen angeeignet,
wie man dagegen vorgehen kann.
Aber wenn man die Lebensgeschichte sieht,
findet man Sexualdelikte,
da gibt es drei Partnerschaften
mit erheblicher Gewalttätigkeit.
Es zieht sich eine Vielzahl von Delikten,
auch schweren Delikten
durch die ganze Biografie.
Es ist völlig absurd, das Bild des
unbescholtenen Bürgers zu transportieren.
Ein unbescholtener Bürger,
der durch den Staat schikaniert wird,
und die Kontrolle verliert.
Hier haben wir es zu tun mit
einem hochmanipulativen Menschen
mit krimineller Energie.
Ein Gewalttäter, der in einer
bestimmten Situation
ganz kalkuliert ein
Delikt begeht,
in dem er es subjektiv
all denen zurückzahlt,
mit denen er offene
Rechnungen hat.
Es ist morgens um halb elf,
als Leibacher innert wenigen
Minuten ein Blutbad anrichtet.
Es ist der erste Anschlag dieser Art
in der Schweiz.
Urbaniok wird beauftragt,
ein Gutachten über den toten Täter zu verfassen.
In dem Fall lagen noch günstige
Voraussetzungen vor,
weil der Täter unglaublich
viel geschrieben hat.
Er hatte so eine
querulatorische Seite,
er hat Tagebuch geführt.
Es gab keinen Mangel an Dokumenten.
Es waren tausende von Seiten.
Das war schon eine sehr gute Grundlage,
um die Biografie zu rekonstruieren.
Zudem gab es früher bereits
Strafverfahren,
in denen viel dokumentiert war.
Sie waren bis dato
aber nicht zusammengeführt.
Das war eine wichtige Quelle.
Und es gab Personen,
die den Täter kannten
aus der Kindheit und der Jugend.
Wenn man das alles zusammennahm,
dann gab es in diesem Fall sogar
eine überdurchschnittlich gute Informationsbasis.
Leibacher machte seine Drohungen wahr.
Das heisst noch lange nicht, dass alle
die drohen, gefährlich sind.
Die meisten Menschen,
die drohen, begehen keine Taten.
Fast immer sind Drohungen harmlos.
Aber nur fast.
Immer wenn die Drohung zusammentrifft
mit einer Risiko-Persönlichkeit,
also einer Persönlichkeit,
in der es Eigenschaften gibt,
die verstärkt zu Gewalt disponieren.
Die Kombination von konkreter Drohung
und einer Risiko-Persönlichkeit
ist sehr kritisch.
Um das zu erkennen, sind wir
wieder im normalen Gebiet
der forensischen Risikokalkulation.
Da schaut man
die Eigenschaften der Person an,
und schaut, ob es Eigenschaften gibt,
die ein Risiko bedeuten.
Nur wenn die Kombi vorliegt von
Risikofaktoren und gefährlicher Drohung,
ist es gefährlich.
Das ist nur ein kleiner Anteil
von Drohungen, aber es ist ein hochrelevanter.
Auffällig ist der Zeitpunkt des Amoklaufs.
Kurz nach den Anschlägen auf
die Twin Towers in New York.
Ein Detail in diesem Fall ist auch,
dass dieser Täter vor dem Fernseher sass
und 9/11 gesehen hat.
Er war völlig fasziniert davon.
Er fand das positiv,
er fand das toll,
und es faszinierte ihn.
Es ist aus meiner Sicht auch kein Zufall,
dass er zwei Wochen später selber
so ein Delikt begeht.
Wir wissen, dass potenzielle
«Amoktäter»
sich sehr für andere Amoktaten interessieren.
Sie nehmen solche dann oft als Anlass,
umzusetzen, was sie
schon längere Zeit geplant haben.
Kurz nach der Tat interviewte das
Schweizer Fernsehen einen,
der den Zuger Behörden
ebenfalls bestens bekannt war
durch seine Drohungen.
Vor laufender Kamera dachte er laut
über einen Amoklauf nach.
– Können Sie sich so etwas auch vorstellen? –
Ob ich mir das vorstellen kann?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich fand das verantwortungslos.
Weil in einer so zugespitzten Zeit ...
Man muss sich auch die
Situation in Zug noch einmal vorstellen,
der ganze Kanton war unter Schock,
viele Personen kannten jemanden,
der zum Teil aus der Familie war.
Und wir sassen da in
einer Task-Force zusammen,
und hatten Fälle,
bei denen wir uns fragen mussten,
ob das Nachahmungstäter sein könnten.
Könnten die auf den Zug aufspringen?
Da gab es einige,
die kündigten so etwas an.
Wenn man in einer so aufgeheizten, schwierigen Situation dann noch jemandem
eine Plattform im Fernsehen gibt,
wird so ein Fall und die Publizität
auf eine schlechte Art und Weise instrumentalisiert.
Das SRF berichtet heute anders über
Gewalttäter und ihre Taten.
Seien es islamistische Terroristen
im Nahen Osten
oder der rechtsradikal motivierte
Massenmord im neuseeländischen
Christchurch mit 50 Toten.
Oder der Norweger Anders Breivik.
Zum einen ist es ganz wichtig,
dass man solche Täter nicht noch
ungewollt idealisiert.
Das passiert schon schnell durch Superlative,
indem man sagt,
der grösste Massenmörder aller Zeiten.
Und ihn dann vielleicht noch in
einer heroischen Geste zeigt,
wir haben das bei Breivik gesehen.
Man muss sich als Medienschaffender
vor allem eine Frage stellen,
wenn man berichtet über solche Fälle.
Das, was ich jetzt produziere,
kann das bei
verwirrten Geistern Kultstatus erlangen?
Wir kennen die Diskussion bei Breivik,
das Victory-Zeichen.
Das sollte man sich als Gegenprobe immer fragen.
Können Menschen
die einen Kult daraus machen,
das Material für eine Idealisierung verwenden?
Zweitens sollte man sich
in die Opfer hineinversetzen
und sich überlegen,
ob für die Betroffenen
ein bestimmter Beitrag retraumatisierend
sein könnte.
Ist es für sie sogar bedrohlich?
Wenn das der Fall ist,
dann sollte man die Finger davon lassen.